sometimes i think stereotypically women
in general are a little more relational
we're not shamed for being relational as
much
we're still shamed for being relational
and vulnerable but not as much
as men so um but in my
yeah and my role here is very much to
keep
you know you just i'm constantly just
checking to see what needs to be
addressed who needs to be hugged
and then i have some great therapists
for me and that's amen
amen for therapy moment of silence
yes i agree
i like i can't i actually i
i i've come around and around on therapy
because like
i did it a 100 years ago when i was
married and then it just didn't end well
and then i was like screw therapy and
then
you know i went for a span of time that
there was none of that and then all of a
sudden it was like
all of a sudden after the last
relationship it was like
i need therapy and then i'm like wait a
second
people should always be in therapy and
you should be doing your own
therapy like i believe in couples
therapy sure but
not if you're not doing your own well i
think they kind of go together
because there are certain things that
you
that i'm only going to dive into if it's
just about me in that moment you know
it's a
super deep dive some parts i do a lot of
ifs
internal family systems therapy and
what's great about that particular model
for me is that
it's the deep dive alone facilitated
by a great therapist and then to me the
idea of couples ifs therapy meaning we
can
this part of you can speak with this
part of me and
is this like parts therapy or is this a
different kind of
is there any actual modalities used
other than sort of verbal and going
inward or is is there
this isn't something like emdr or
anything like that is it
uh it's a model it's richard schwartz
started it i just wrote the forward for
his new book that's coming out it's
called no bad parts
and i've been i've been a parts girl for
as long as i can remember i just
you know if someone said ask me how i
was feeling i would say well one part of
me
feels this and the other 13 parts feel
this
but we have that even in our family with
my kids if i ask anyone how they're
feeling it's usually more than one
answer
that's interesting do you think that
that is and like
something they're born with or something
that you've taught them like do they
have you given them the tools to tap
into that or is it
sort of a modeling i think it's a
straight-up curiosity like
how are you feeling about that you know
and
what part of you feels that or what part
of you thinks that that you know
it's just a curiosity about their parts
and then
because i know richard schwartz's model
so well and i'm obsessed with it
um it's just part of our family's
lingo now you know i mean parts work is
just you know
carl young and then segwayed into debbie
ford really taking it to another level i
think her work really
blossomed it into culture a little more
and then richard schwartz just taking it
to a whole other level
we're like casually dropping in here but
i feel like it's because we had
like two and a half hours when we did
the
lindsay zarniak um artist in the athlete
interview
and we just sat there and you and i i
was like i felt kind of bad for lindsay
because
pluto didn't you know she didn't get a
word in very
much but like we just went on and on so
i feel like this
this interview is like a continuation of
the conversation we were having which
has so much to do with the internal work
and spirituality
and orientation and perception
um triggers projections all the damn
words
all the damn words but like it can't be
missed that i'm just such
like you're just as i was getting ready
for this it's like man you are my
all-time favorite artist
and so i'm like pausing for a moment to
remember
how much i just like love your music so
i know that we just like
totally dropped into all kinds of things
but i
feel like people should just know how
big of a fan i
am and how um how interesting it is how
much we resonate on this other level
that really is like
you know nothing to do with scent
essentially it's not music we're not
talking about an album we're not talking
about a tour
although i want to and we will do
because i have like tickets from all
directions for the tour
that's all i know i think that's
interesting
how i can be such a big fan and here we
are on
in this whole other way connecting why
do you think that is
do you think is there some kind of
resonance that is unspoken
yeah i think and sometimes we do speak
it you know it's just it's
it's a value system so i think what we
value
is is resonant and if we want to break
down what some of those are
you know we value i value connection and
i believe you do too
just even your capacity for intimacy and
and connection and wanting to
even have a bond you know our our
survival strategies might be similar we
love to
we love conversation we might we might
be the same number on the enneagram i
have no idea
um but also i think you and i are up for
the deep dive
of diving into the unknown you know
there's a there's a sort of
constitutional type of
temperament and spirit i think and for
you know
this the symbology of pedal to the metal
foot on the brake i mean that's me all
the time i'm
i'm going 100 miles an hour and then i
realize i have to stop and
the gears are grinding but i'm like oh
sorry i'm using this freaking metaphor
with you of all people
you should it's totally so not sorry i
think you and i
have the similarity of curiosity too and
i like to just know the
the lowest common denominator i love
breaking things down to their essence or
to
you know to why something why i was
acting out in a certain way or why i was
quiet and
you know i just i'm really curious um
about
this human condition you know it's not
always easy to be in these
these meat sacks i love the little
there's like a little gif or meme or
whatever it is and it's
it shows uh somebody down on earth in a
little bubble of thoughts like like
this coming to earth thing was a lot
harder than i thought it'd be
right amen yeah it's really hard my aunt
and i we communicate a lot and she's
always like why do you come here this is
an interesting journey for
for everyone frankly you know but it's
you know there's some tools as we know
but trying to figure out toolfulness in
the
from ego is already kind of set up to
lose in a way
if if the goal is to be just happy you
know if the goal is to be just
one state i don't think emotional states
were built to be constant i mean they're
all messenger you know messengers and
messages for us so
for me it's about the degree of
listening and tuning in and when i'm not
doing it i feel disconnected from god
and from myself and from my loved ones
and
it doesn't it's not a comfortable
feeling that's when it's not fun to be
in the body for me
but when the connection is fostered and
i am
you know looking at different parts and
communicating from this really really
soulful place that i could feel
connected to life and everyone around me
but
it's uh you know the the the chase of
the happiness thing was really trendy
for like
50 years and i think it's i think now
it's the
for me the chase if there is an egoic
chase it's to
stop resisting how hard it is to be
human sometimes and how beautiful it is
too
is your aunt alive you said communicate
okay i wasn't sure if you were
oh yeah i do that too but she happens to
be in her body so it's so funny you know
what's so funny is before this i was
like
i thought i'm like i wonder what you're
like if you have what your psychic
capacity is
yeah i mean i can definitely i can
conjure it
i mean i don't do it a lot but ever
since i was very little i can
i don't know what what the term would be
i do have a capacity to
hear messages or connect with people
who aren't in the body or i have to be
careful though so i think it's
it's being an empath so 30 of people
highly sensitive
um and then of that 30 20 to 30 percent
um
four percent of them are empaths and
some of them are
medium type empaths some of them are
animal and past plant empaths you know
and they're linked to the intelligences
so you asked about my capacity and it's
really
i think it's a gift you know it's scary
sometimes to be picking up
so much information no matter what and
that's one of the stresses cortisol
for the reintegration into this new
normal is the idea of like wow okay i
have to
i have to pace myself and you know i
just pick up on
so much information that i you know i
just have to prepare myself for hiding
in bathrooms again
yeah i well i mean i think that that's
that's more
i mean there's there's people out there
that deal with that i mean i have a
couple of friends who just you know pick
up a lot of energy
and it's not how i work but um
uh what are the tools because i i feel
like there's got to be someone that's
like oh my god that's me
i walk around and there's all this
information and it's so overwhelming
and then i feel like that also
contributes to
you know how much anxiety is out there
in the world and how many people suffer
with anxiety because that's a real thing
and
i didn't actually i mean i didn't
experience it until
last year a couple of times and i was
like oh my god what is this
like full-blown panic attack you mean or
um like
unable to get out of a thought like i
couldn't choose a good thought right
like i was sort of like
spinning ruminating yeah yeah exactly
and it just kind of
created a lot of like you know body
heart rate panic um yes like rampant
journaling all of a sudden trying to get
something out
and i had never i'd i mean i really only
had it probably three times
but it was it gave me this new
understanding for what it's like to pick
up energy because it was when i was
picking up the energy
of something else and someone else that
it would happen
and so you know i think that's uh that's
something
people really deal with and it's hard to
find your way out of it and there's
there's
there have been so many more books and
much more literature
being made available now about about
being an empath there's a woman rose
rose tree who's written
a few books i think one of them was
called empowered empath the master
empath
um you know and and there's different
schools i i
really enjoy when the distinction is
kept between empath and hsp because
um they're not the same what's the
difference
um highly sensitive temperament you know
the acronym that elaine aaron goes with
um she coined the phrase and is a
brilliant brilliant mind and heart um
and i had the privilege of of being in a
documentary that she made
entitled sensitive and and one of the
best ways she describes it is it is by
the acronym does so
d for depth of processing for a highly
sensitive
um oh for over stimulation or quickly
overstimulated in that as an hsp i can
walk in the room and
if a non-hsp were to pick up 50
pieces of information upon walking into
a room in theory the highly sensitive
temperament picks up on 500 pieces so it
would make sense then that
highly sensitive need to kind of pace
ourselves and
recalibrate it doesn't take me long
either there are some nights where i'll
turn to my son and my husband and i'll
just
say if i don't have six minutes of
complete silence i'll be back in six
minutes
you know i can't even be here my head's
gonna pop off emoji
so um and the the
the retelling of the soil can happen
really quickly and then the empath
sorry i didn't finish the acronym then e
for um empathy
you know a tendency toward being extra
empathic um
and and deeply felt emotions you know
like sometimes
someone will feel something and i'll
feel it in my chest it feels almost
debilitating you know and um
not everyone feels it so debilitatingly
in the in the body
um and then s for subtleties sort of
attuned to subtleties and
you know picking up on certain smells
and all the senses basically
and then empath is just a different kind
of attunement
and awareness and and the picking up
of people's energy or you know i used to
have it as a kid too i remember once my
brother
hurt his ankle and then i couldn't walk
you know so i would have sort of this
physical
body empath um thing but in rose
roester's book she literally breaks down
the kinds of empaths and the good news
and the confusing news is that there are
a lot of books coming out right now and
most of them agree with each other but
it's
the exciting thing is that it's part of
the conversation now because in the
psychotherapeutic community
no one wanted to talk about two things
they didn't want to talk about they
didn't want to talk about attachment
parenting and attachment
theory which i think now we're kind of
blending it together as
as humans um and they also
no one wanted to touch temperament i
don't know why until
elaine aaron came around so the more we
can talk about this i think the better
because there are
all these artists in the 27 club and
people committing suicide and depression
and anxiety i mean it's
so much of it is born from being
sensitive and from being an empath
and if we're not equipped to even
understand what that is
we're subject to thinking that you know
we're cursed or that there's something
wrong with us or
when the opposite is true you know we do
have to be responsible for it though
you know i have to be really clear about
what i need in order to do something and
that could be
that could be as simple as is there a
room that has a door that i can go in
at the office that we're going to yes
okay great
i can go you know but if there's nowhere
to hide or there's nowhere to regroup
it's it's a rough one